welcome back to glamour unfiltered host
by meet Josh Smith and today we're
joined by two living Queens of Disney
and gingili Al Fanning how are you I was
in bits watching this towards the end
like full-on sobs in the cinema and what
was so amazing for me is the kind of
journey of self-discovery both for your
characters go on what is your own
journey of self-discovery been like for
you and what would you say have been the
biggest turning points in that I've had
many I think I think it's that you it is
very important to me that the film
speaks about finding your true self and
being your true self no matter how
people see you or what they feel you
should be and to accept each other and
to want for other people to be I see
somebody who's not being themselves and
I feel like it could take a choking
feeling like they just can't they can't
breathe and and so many people are
living that way whether it be the
politics of the country they're in or
the home they live in and it's and it's
horrible
so I've certainly haven't had situations
like some and so I don't want to
complain but I have had things that have
made me not feel I can breathe and I've
had to fight to find them how did you
fight to find that my children helped me
and I guess you go through a certain
point of pain or loss and you just you
you either go down or you get back up
what's that been like for you out they
think for everyone you have to find your
fight my mom always says joy says like
the way you handle disappointments is
what defines you and I've always kind of
took that and you know you can either
you can do one of two things you can get
back up or you know kind of drown and
your sorrows about it so you have to
learn to to you know rise above the
water I think but I think that's a great
little saying
she always says 100% so we should all
probably be following our own lives as
well for sure I know that's crazy I was
thinking about the fact that in this
magnificent has so many hover her own
critics around her and she also has her
own South critic as well what is your
relationship with like criticism and
South and your own self critic been like
for both of you I don't feel like I've
ever been without criticism or judgment
or I was a bit odd growing up and a bit
of a punk and a bit of a different and
and I was never the the like popular
regular and and I kind of never wanted
to be so it was okay I never really
sought approval maybe it's cuz I did
have a strong mother who loved me and so
I didn't feel like I had I wasn't okay
I'm I'm self-critical and really hard on
myself that I don't do enough and I
wonder always if I'm being a good enough
mom or if I'm being a good enough person
if I'm doing enough but I do know that
when I put my head in the pillow at
night I I Know Who I am inside and I
know I I am a good person I know I wish
people well and I'm and you know so I
you kind of when you know your inner
self and you and really my kids my kids
can tell you they just tell you I'm
silly that tells me everything I need to
know when they have a crazy like they're
[ __ ] they think I'm funny and I tend
to be the one that goes and gets the
band-aid so that's that's that's all I
need to know about me yeah for sure what
about you out gosh I think I mean
obviously people are gonna judge
everyone like that sadly that's kind of
the world we live in people love to
judge people and you know that that's
the story that you know people want to
read negative stories just so that's the
way it works like that you know that
well they'll click on that and let's see
this the dirt and I've never really I
haven't been someone that's you know
read like oh like what critics say and
like been like crazy about it is I I
mean also I feel like don't give them
power like they're saying something
about you don't give them power in that
and they hate that more you know which I
love like hate that that I don't care
yeah yes I think you know try to of
course you know I am sensitive to things
but you have to don't give them the
power one of the most amazing things
about this film is this incredible cross
generational relationship and I know
with your work in as an activist you've
done so many amazing things to raise
younger generations of women up when you
come to doing a film like this where
that message is so profound and so
powerful how important is that for you
and for both of you that relationship
it's very important I don't think it's
never been something I was very close to
my mother I've always felt the strength
of women and I spent a lot of time in
societies where the women women aren't
well certainly many where women are
oppressed but many where it is and
almost always the strong center of a
community and I've never I've never not
seen the community of women or the
strength or never not relied on it but I
I think I think it's very important to
be strong as women and be together and
have that community and support each
other and I also think which this film
says it's very important to learn from
be close to and identify the strengths
and the men around you yes and there are
many great men in the film and that was
really important to us that it wasn't
isolated that you find strength together
as women which many are trying to do now
and speaking up about and somehow that
means separate from the men in your life
and it's very important to to come
together and help them also understand
and be a part of this because we're not
gonna get progress unless we bring men
along for the ride as well right and we
there are sons and husbands fathers
boyfriends it's we we we are and women
in our nature were very nurturing a lot
of people are of course but it is in it
is not in our nature to I don't think
we're born like we're not born to fight
and laughs it's not born well she may be
but I think you may have it in her butt
but I think you're born to you know you
you want to just fight for what you
believe in you don't want to be fighting
to survive hmm and I think there's a big
difference and we have to help a lot of
women to get past that place where
they're just fighting to survive because
there's also in this a lot of power and
vulnerability and when she when
Maleficent taps into a vulnerability
like your character as well
it almost empowers them in a way which I
found really profound can you remember a
time in your own lives where you've
tapped into your own vulnerability like
this has actually made me a much much
stronger person to me the actors that I
love to watch the most are the most
vulnerable and open to the audience and
for me I always try to to remember that
in that weakness you know is also can be
your strength too and and I know that
those times I love I actually really
love kind of feeling vulnerable on set
that odd to say I do but you know what I
mean it's like there's something so open
and raw and you're just like there and
for me it kind of can be very cathartic
to have like a really just emotional
vulnerable experience and also you know
a lot of the time you get of course
you're the set you become family but in
a way you're kind of around strangers so
in a funny way you kind of I feel more
comfortable because they don't know me
so I can kind of go there like if it was
in front of my family or my friends
maybe I wouldn't want to show that side
of myself but on set I feel more
comfortable because you know we're all
working together to do this thing and
they don't necessarily know what I'm
going through but it's a space where I
can just like you know you go in the
woods and scream you know so I think
like vulnerability is really is key and
my my life you know for my art but also
you know you do seem like you've always
been it is and it's part of the strength
of Aurora it's part of the strength of
Elle she's never shut off her emotional
life she's somebody who has who wears it
and who wears her softness and who who
is strong enough to wear that softness
which a lot of people there
they're not mmm because what's your
relationship with memorability been like
would you say what is my relation very
similar to Maleficent's yeah we are not
comfortable with it
on an incredible film after being such
amazing empowering role models by
society as well because I think you two
you're just both amazing thank you luck
has been so incredible I've always
admired it so I keep fighting that fight
thank you so much guys
[Music]